bien nicolas et marc cassivi bonsoir
accepté notre invitation
je vous avoue que nous on était un peu
surpris d'apprendre que la chaîne en
ligne qui allait devenir la nouvelle
double 07 avec le permis de tuer qui va
avec
ou est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
hollywood est en train d'entendre le
message
ça fait très longtemps que les routes
s'est réveillé après à cette campagne de
ask the white hacker 2016 qui a été
initiée par épreuve qu'on a reçu
d'ailleurs official film de toronto
donc depuis lors sa après un coup de
barre ils ont changé les règles même à
l'académie des oscars pour pouvoir
permettre à plus de gens dette
le cg de voter ils ont plein de choses
se sont passées il n'y a pas eu que
black panther et ayéva du vernet qui a
eu 100 millions $ pour faire un film
c'est la première fois qu'une femme est
en plus une femme noire à ussat écoute
hollywood est en train vraiment de
montrer que la diversité bas c'est eux
qui vont triompher là dedans aussi
on attendait près plus un acteur noir
idris elba on parler de lui depuis
longtemps le génie pression en fait ce
qu'on sait pour l'instant c'est que
cette cette actrice va jouer l'agent 007
parce que jingbian qui est interprété
par daniel craig prend sa retraite mais
je pense qu'on laisse la porte ouverte à
toutes sortes de scénarios donc est ce
que c'est vraiment c'est pas c'est pour
réellement james et prend pas le rôle de
james bond mais c'est quand même un
décision assez étonnante est
intéressante il fait rare et historique
qui fait réagir puis je pense que c'est
bien que ça fasse réagir aussi cette
affaire on n'est pas non plus rendu au
point où ce genre de décision fait
réagir personne puis en france pour heck
parce que selon ce qu'on lit du scénario
james bond daniel craig pardon va être
toujours présent dans lequel il va même
si la séduire un moment donné donc on a
l'impression du producteur se garde
quand même peut-être une porte de sortie
si jamais ça marche pas si bien que ça
avec la chana lynch aurait rennais
daniel graig non s'il ya un point de non
retour ici moi je rentrerai pas du tout
dans les détails du scénario les
intentions des auteurs ce que je dirais
c'est que disney a été très constant
consiste à comme on dit ça constant dans
ses décisions d'inclusion il à la
nouvelle ariel par exemple
nouvelle ariel et noir aussi il y a eu
quand il a mis un acteur noir dans star
wars il ya quelques années et puis tout
le monde disait mais voyons avec une
actrice pas connu non plus qu'ils
étaient là comme l'actrice principale à
ses côtés donc je pense que 19 d'entre
eux vraiment de donner une leçon
d'inclusion à tout le monde ça veut dire
que souvent les gens vont dire oui mais
historiquement on peut permettre la
diversité là parce qu'historiquement les
personnalités blanc et là ils montrent
que c'est c'est à nous de refaire
l'histoire l'histoire nous appartient on
le fait comme on veut et aujourd'hui on
est en 2019
et voilà mais reste marque que l'on
laisse étiez qu'on lit les gens issus de
la diversité aux états unis représente
qu'un pour cent de la population or ils
ne sont que 15 à 20% des rôles
principaux au cinéma ou à la télévision
est quand même encore beaucoup de
travail à faire il reste beaucoup de
travail à faire et on le voit aussi dans
les réactions donc 77
ariel la petite sirène qui va être joué
et qui va être donc un personnage noir
ça fait beaucoup réagir aux états unis
allaient une certaine droite et jean
puis conservateur qui acceptent poste ce
genre de choses ce qui ce qui étonne la
même réaction face à ce personnage dans
james bond effectivement il ya plus de
diversité aux etats-unis que ce qui
apparaît à l'écran mais c'est déjà
beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on voit au
québec mais faudrait aussi il marque que
la population noire aux états unis ne
représentent que 13% et là on est
beaucoup plus de 13% deux personnes
noires à l'école déjà et à la télévision
on ne peut pas avoir une série en heure
de grande écoute ce qui est pas de
personnages principaux dont je pense que
les etats unis sont très en avance sur
nous ont certainement sur nous alors
juste pour comprendre parce que ça peut
pas être une question saugrenue il ya
probablement des gens qui se posent la
question à la maison marque
pourquoi c'est important de montrer la
diversité à l'écran
pourquoi c'est si important pourquoi
c'est si une bataille c'est important
pour ceux qui la mène
je pense que c'est simplement de
refléter à l'écran ce qu'est la société
par exemple à montréal il ya plus de la
moitié des gens qui sont issus de
l'immigration soit des gens qui sont nés
à l'étranger ou qui sont des enfants
d'immigrants de première génération
on voit pas du tout ça à l'écran à
l'écran
québécois c'est très très blanc toutes
les études de nos corps et quand c'est
des noms italiens
évidemment c'était souvent des
personnages qui sont liées au crime
organisé ont été testées avaient
anticipé aussi dans le genre de
personnage et donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de chemin à faire
simplement pour représenter la société
québécoise est bon on parle beaucoup de
montréal passe quand même la moitié du
québec le tiers des personnes sont nées
à l'étranger
on ne voit pas du tout ni un ni au
cinéma ni a été ouverte selon un
recensement de l'udps et à l'union des
artistes en 2014 5% des acteurs au
théâtre et à la télévision étaient issus
de minorités ethniques au visible alors
la question qui tue fabien le milieu du
divertissement québécois est il raciste
dans son approche face aux acteurs qui
viennent de la partie oui québécois non
je pense pas qu'il y ait un milieu
raciste ici au québec mois par ailleurs
si peu de représentations je pense
qu'elle de la ferme sûr qu'il ya de la
peur est qu'il y ait une espèce de
laxisme genre on ne sait pas où les
trouver il y en a pas qui savent jouer
assez haut et cetera ben je pense que
quand on en a vraiment besoin et on doit
trouver on entre home
mais quand il n'y a pas de quotas il
n'ya pas d'incitatif etc en trouve plein
d'excusés je vais vous donner un exemple
ce serait très triste de voir la petite
sirène ou de voir c'est ce ce nouveau
bond james bond avec l'as wihr otheros
aigles noirs et le voir que ces doubles
et entièrement par des genres blanc
c'est ce qui se passe en si la prochaine
étape donc pour vous c'est de savoir si
l'achat d'un lynch est doublé par c'est
important parce qu'ils ont une étude qui
a été fait justement par hadj pas une
étude mais un reportage qui a été fait
par radio canada qui montrait que
pendant qu'on se réjouissait de tous les
films américains black et c'est bertrand
heures et tout aidé pendant ce temps
l'entièreté du de des gens qui jouaient
ce héros là qu'ils étaient des noirs il
y était doublée au québec par des blancs
alors il y a aussi cette réalité de
savoir que au québec on est tellement en
arrière mais dans tous les points de vue
donc il faut se battre il faut continuer
à avancer c'est noir il exerce ses
acteurs de minorités visibles
ils sont là il faut aller les chercher
fall a ouvert les portes et puis il faut
pour les inclure je vous rappeler la
controverse
de cela les primes et donc marque d'un
milieu du divertissement québécois
pourquoi il ya si peu de minorité
représentée à l'écran bon souvent on va
dire est-ce que c'est l'oeuf ou la poule
est ce que parce que les acteurs se
reconnaissent pas à l'écran où les
jeunes issus de différentes communautés
serveurs se voit pas à l'écran on pas
l'impression qu'ils aient une place pour
eux sur les planches de théâtre et au
cinéma ou à la télévision
est ce que c'est les producteurs est ce
que ce sont les dix les diffuseurs qui
ont qui font pas ta place pour ces
acteurs là où pour ces jeunes là c'est
un espèce de grand changement de roue
qui tourne mais les choses changent
il ya des auditions de la diversité qui
se font on essaie au théâtre d'ouvrir
tout ça il ya au moins une prise de
conscience depuis quelques années de ce
problème et slaves ont été un exemple je
pense que tout se fait avancer les
chômeurs les consciences évoluent les
consciences évoluent mais que les
consciences évoluent et aujourd'hui on
n'a que faire de la conscience il faut
passer à l'action
c'est un bébé pleure on peut pas dire
j'ai conscience que tu as faim il faut
la nourrir
alors ça alors c'est quoi l'action est
ce qui se passe en ce moment l'action en
ce moment il faut que l'idée à essai de
deux mètres cubes du ciment de lui des
amis pour vraiment s'assurer que les
acteurs issus de la diversité ont leurs
chansons en une facilité à entrer pour
devenir membre actif aussi ça c'est
difficile parce que si tu as 50 fois
moins de chances d'avoir des rôles c'est
sûr que tu as 50 fois moins de chances
de cumuler des crédits rapidement donc
ceci pas vrai que c'est cesser de
l'équité que de te demander les mêmes
nombre de crédits déjà mesure
inscription des mesures ville et moi et
moi je pense que les quotas c'est
incontournable quand on a voulu en
double et le film à manama
aminata qui est la traduction de
bouconne migros de mon ami clément
rigaud et des caisses qu'ils ont dit ils
ont dit et bien la version qui va passer
au québec elle doit être doublé par des
personnages noirs qui doutent des noirs
alors ce feu et la directrice de casser
l'a dit mon dieu selon votre reportage
d'ailleurs de radio canada est bien là
quand on a eu cette commande là bas on a
dû faire des appels on a préludé à on
appelait si on appelait ça on a dû
former des acteurs etc et on y est a
réussi et des quotas c'est un producteur
qui met son point fort et dakota c'est
comme c'est ça qui va se passer c'est ça
qu'on demande
travailleur quoi quand il y à des
mesures coercitives quand on demande des
quotas quand on dit c'est ça qui se
passe on trouve des solutions et les
connaisseurs c'est le gouvernement qui
doit les imposer on va pas du tout les
quotas je pense que c'est l'industrie
artistique qui doit les opposer le
gouvernement ça veut dire le téléfilm
canada la sodec etc vous imaginez demain
matin si on disait il n'ya pas d'argent
qui va être donnée à des films qui
n'inclut pas la diversité ou des
miliciens qui n'occupe à l'adversité à
parts égales du marché qu'est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils allaient arriver
pas d'argent pas du film eh bien laissez
moi très bien on va trouver de la
diversité mais pour lui il ya aucune
raison que cela change si on pousse par
ben ils le font d'ailleurs en télévision
à radio canada les nouvelles émissions
font que ce genre d'initiative il faut
qu'ils aient des gens issus de la
diversité dans les projets de fiction
qui sont présentés bon ça ça fait aussi
jaser y ait des gens qui trouvent que
c'est limitatif ousséini restrictif moi
je pense je suis d'accord avec avec
fabienne qu'il faut parfois forcer les
choses pour la note pour que les choses
se passaient pas si bush
eh bien merci d'avoir participé à
l'émission ce soir
[Rires]